welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about
who is the valedictorian of the mcu
villain high school class of 2021
my name is mt and with me today is the
amazingly
awesome and beautiful um and the other
half of peaches and cream
tommy backtoe what's going on tommy big
head gang
let me hear you
oh great to be back with you my man
happy belated birthday
happy and you know what let me get let
me get ahead of next year happy birthday
next year as well
so oh shoot you are you're the first
person to say happy
30th birthday to me tommy what's up big
trio baby
big three three decades of uh just being
weird yeah yeah
no other way depression
really dark we both laughed at that
because we're in pain
it's just darkness on the inside yes in
the darkness
why god why are you doing this to us
with loki premiering soon on disney plus
we'll soon be reintroduced to a
mischievous loki
from the past who has yet to embrace his
more heroic and altruistic side so
whether he's trying to save the day or
just looking out for number one
we love loki for all of his his clever
schemes and his machinations so that's
got a thinking about this week's big
question
who are the smartest villains in the mcu
yes the villains were ranking today all
have a long and elaborate story in the
comics so
to try and keep it somewhat fair we're
going to look at the mcu versions of
these marvel villains okay just keep it
in the films
maybe a little bit of tv i don't want to
say yet there are some villains on this
list that have not yet appeared in the
mcu but we expect them
to be coming sometime soon so we
included them anyway
sorry haters we apologize haters but
that's just how it's going to be
yeah our rankings today are based on
intelligence
as well as cleverness and effectiveness
of their evil plans
so let's dive in with our first villain
the mandarin
wenwoo himself from the upcoming shang
chi
movie now we don't know the exact extent
of when wu's intelligence until the
release of the movie
coming out later this year but we
imagine that he has to be fairly
intelligent because
of his experience i mean mandarin is an
ancient warrior king
who has been inspiring people since back
in the middle ages
so we know he's been around for a very
long time and he must have picked up
some knowledge along the way and he's
managed to stay under the radar for most
of the time he's been alive pretty much
and
our heroes were completely unaware of
his existence for the most part until
this point
because he's been more so like a myth
figure than like really just like a main
player and it's pretty smart because he
seems to have a fairly successful
empire i mean from the trailer he's
landing a helicopter into this huge base
full of people and i'm assuming he's
paying them all
so he has to be very successful right um
unless this is all a volunteer thing
then uh i guess could you imagine
volunteering for that like you know what
i said this year i was going to
volunteer more who's got opportunities
he just has flyers up at ymca he's like
is there something missing in your life
and of course the 10 marines is a very
successful terrorist organization
and they're actually one of the first
bad guys that we see in the mcu of
course
in iron man 1 the people that kidnapped
tony in the first place are part of the
10 rings
terrorist organization so you know even
though they weren't successful in
keeping tony stark
my turn
they have been successful in other plots
around the years considering that
they're still around
yes even now in 2023 in the end yes
that's right
yes and of course he possesses the ten
rings which
in the movie tends to be like i think
it's more like the ten like arm
bracelets which is kind of weird but
which so far appears to be a pretty
smart move
of his to to utilize and have because i
feel like if you have the ten rings
you have to be sort of intelligent to
use them because they
they don't seem like um like regular
human technology i think
they probably like work with the chi of
one's body and like all this stuff so
you kind of have to be a smart cookie to
utilize those rings so i like it
all right number nine is a bad guy we
haven't seen
much of yet we've only only been teased
and that is leader
we receive [ __ ] yes yes
the leader we receive just a little
sample of leader in the incredible hulk
when samuel stearns is exposed to some
of hulk's gamma-irritated blood
and begins to get that big brain energy
big head gang
[Music]
again oh yes [ __ ] wow we gotta hold on
we got
lumbers now wow this is huge uh just
like our heads
so will he be back anytime soon let's
talk about what he's got going on
super genius intelligence he has a
perfect memory and can recall
any moment since the accident he has a
ton of potential theoretically is
capable of learning anything
and mastering any worldly subject could
you imagine that on a date
you go on a first date the person tells
you their interest
the second date you literally know
everything about it so you can mansplain
to them
maybe that is not a good thing let me
dial that back that might be more of a
curse than a gift
so he has the ability to predict
outcomes which gives him a tactical
advantage let me know who's going to win
these play-in tournament games in the
nba please
leader if you're watching this uh he has
very strong intuition which means his
hunches are almost
always correct so that's pretty strong i
mean yeah i hope we get leader back soon
and then we get to see more of his
high jinks wow um all of leaders uh
abilities sound like things that my
ex-girlfriend had
yeah great predominantly intuition
strong into a memory recall to remember
all the bad things i've done
oh my god wait did we date the same girl
uh
i think we did i think that's uh i think
that's why they call this big head game
that's right
we got it from our ex oh god that's
terrible i shouldn't say that why would
you say that
like you put me in such an uncomfortable
situation like you know i'm not happy
number eight on our list has got to be
um one of my personal favorite villains
i know a lot of people don't like them
but
ultron i think ultron is fantastic and
of course
he's super smart because he's a robot
he's built by you know the smartest man
in the world but one of
ultron's main um and most impressive
abilities and probably the first one he
ever used
was his ability to scan the entire
history of humanity
on the planet in mere moments and
realizes that we know we're pretty much
the problem with everything which you
know
he's not wrong he's not exactly wrong
but
after he creates himself using tony
stark's technology without his
permission while tony
stark is partying with his friends like
some type of
cool sociable man i'm like boom
you looking for this that's what you get
tony stark shouldn't have been
should have been doing that should have
been focused on your nerd [ __ ] that's
what you should have been home studying
right that's why i don't have friends
that's me too you never know where your
pocket was gonna start that's right i'm
always just working that's why i don't
go on a lot of dates i'm too busy with
my craft
but yes after ultron makes himself be
using tony stark's technology
he pulls himself up by his digital
bootstraps and keeps making
nicer and more powerful bodies for
himself so that's
a pretty smart thing to do because i
can't do that with my body i know i wish
i could
i'm always trying to get rid of mine uh
i'm trying to freaky friday with
everyone i just anytime i shake hands
with someone i whisper
right but it never works and ultron was
able to develop his own machines and
technology
giving himself power such as telekinesis
which is just pretty damn cool right i
wish i had another telekinesis very cool
and he's able to go toe-to-toe in combat
with the avengers and like one of my
favorite sequences of that movie is when
cap
and ultron are fighting on top of that
truck that's pretty cool
and then yes and the cap throws the
sharp and ultron's titties it gets stuck
on his chest
and it's rip it out it's great um that
is
a good thing that movie directed itself
[Laughter]
and of course ultron had a very smart
plan of destroying the planet
by ripping a city out of the ground and
dropping it on earth
and even though he was stopped it still
did plenty of damage because
the aftermath of age of ultron pretty
much kicked off civil war and the
aftermath of civil war
is you know kind of left the earth
defenseless for when thanos came so
you know ultron he was stopped but
he really did mess things up he did he
started he started he started a lot of
[ __ ] but without ultron we wouldn't have
zemo
and we wouldn't have the zebo dance so
hey thanks oprah
you know and uh number seven is the
person i like to refer to as the flesh
ultron he's very similar in intellect uh
and ingenuity and that is of course dr
doom uh
a brilliant scientist and engineer he is
a very capable wielder of
magic you're a wizard
given the trend of where the mcu is
going makes
it seem as though dr doom will be around
sooner than later he has designed and
constructed
many devices and machines including his
most successful creation
you know him i know him i love him the
doombots
doombox advanced ai and often a doom in
his schemes even impersonating doom at
times
and distracting people some doombots
like are so
advanced that they actually think that
they're dr doom it's so funny yeah like
some runs are just really great because
like
the dude will freak out and be like wait
i'm not doctor dude i am
mrs nesbit are you kidding me
that's great he has obviously to do that
super genius intelligence he was even
able to cure ben grimm once i mean
that's
uh not a bad skill i think ben's perfect
the way he is but you know maybe
sometimes uh
he doesn't want to be made of rock
anyway right yeah
i mean why would you not want to be made
of rock you could do everything as a
rock man what are you even talking about
what's up complaining ben
yeah perfect talk about being able to
balance
multiple responsibilities juggle two
things at one time he's been able to
stay in power as the dictator of a
country
show his natural talents for leadership
strategy and politics
it's true you can't be a dumb mother if
you want to rule the country man that's
right but speaking of villains that are
coming
very soon we have number six on our list
kang
the conqueror as a time traveling entity
it can be difficult
to judge king's intelligence based on
the time that he comes from i mean when
compared
to our current place on the prime
timeline he's clearly a very smart
fellow
and he understands the intricacies of
time travel in the quantum realm he of
course has the combined knowledge and
experience of his counterparts from
across the multiverse
and can travel across time without
creating like divergences so
you know it's pretty impressive and he
also has access to technology
across time from any world in the
universe so
you know to operate all sorts of
different types of technology
you need uh you need to be smart you
need to have at least
a strong basis in uh hooked on phonics
absolutely
so they work for me yeah
i'm still working on it i'm halfway
through my hooked on phonics we're gonna
get you there don't worry buddy i know
i got kind of tripped up with uh the the
i before except after seed thing i don't
understand that
we're doing great received is an unfair
word coming in at number five
i mean my personal favorite we haven't
seen him in the mcu yet but we have seen
him in a marvel movie it's
magneto baby hey yes
he's described as having genius
intelligence in the comics magneto has a
large depth of knowledge
in many scientific fields especially
genetic engineering and mutation
it's a very groovy mutation he's made
clones artificial beings and he's even
mutated humans
uh to give them powers he's developed
mind control devices as well as devices
that suppress mutant powers
he speaks several languages he's easy on
the eyes
uh he's made many discoveries in
particle physics
this guy can do it all he has designed
magnetically powered aircraft
and spacecraft space stations he's made
things that are
sabotage devices that have metal in them
so that he can manipulate people
he's a dutiful planner and a brilliant
strategist and i'm lucky to call him my
best friend
and brother ladies and gentlemen magneto
my favorite thing that magneto can do um
is uh lift up stadiums it's a nice
little uh
party trick that he does and i enjoy it
every time from being a kid i love
magneto because he would occasionally do
the right thing
even if you're bad every once in a while
you can
i do like that too right i do like
villains that are like multi-layered
because just like i'm i'm evil all the
time that's boring it looks like
magneto's like i'm evil
most of them i'm like 90 10. i'm like
i'm like a nice
ground hamburger i'm 90 lean
but uh you know 10 of the time i'm nice
i love his
his relationship with charles the best
because like it's it's like they're
they're like weird like close friends
but not
best friends but like on again off again
it's great it's just just kiss already
honestly i know oh my god
and please i mean i think patrick
stewart and ian mckellen have kissed so
that's
right like i love their relationship in
real life so you know what just make
them kiss in the comics who cares it's
fine
that's a good number five i do like that
but for number four we gotta talk about
them we gotta talk about them
and i know some people might be upset
that he's just at number four
but baron zemo the man himself he is
a goddamn genius like he is a
calculating villain with no enhanced
powers
but has orchestrated the series of
events in civil war
which of course destroyed the avengers
from the inside out and made the earth
not ready for thanos's arrival and has
killed more super soldiers than anyone
in history he just
he just finds him out and he just hunts
them down and kills them that's just his
main hobby people get mad at him from
murdering super soldiers i'm just like
why
why why are you judging this man don't
kink shame him never let anyone dull
your sparkles emo
don't let your dreams be dreams i'm just
kidding please don't murder anyone
people i'm not giving you permission to
murder they're
we have to testify at like 50 murder
trials over the next five years
and of course his biggest um and most uh
smartest thing that he's ever done
is use the winter soldier um as his
personal weapon he literally
found out how to activate this ancient
weapon and use them
as his own personal weapon and that's
some gangster [ __ ]
supercharged i love zemo he's one of my
favorite uh
characters in the mcu uh but
he's not ranked above this next
character having this character be your
favorite is like having the yankees be
your favorite baseball team
it's not sexy but it is a pathway to
success like
you are gonna be happy ultimately as a
fan it's loki baby it's
our favorite uh god of mischief loki is
clearly one of the most clever
strategists in the mcu
as i said he's the god of mischief after
all he has he's able to take
uh control of the minds of key players
in order to execute
his plans i see hawkeye and eric selvig
he
gets in there and crosses all their
wires and uses them like little puppets
seriously like him controlling eric
selvig was probably the most
smartest thing he could have done
because salvik is one of the smartest
um non-evil people in the mcu he's also
amazing at pulling off double crosses
and then making it a triple cross so he
goes back to doing the right thing it's
like
ha ha you thought i was doing the right
thing but i was secretly doing the wrong
thing
so it's kind of all built around this
big crew with like a cool double cross
and then this big awesome twist where
there's like another double cross
he's also really good at talking his way
out of bad situations which is a skill i
wish i had oh yeah i can't do that for
[ __ ] like if i'm
if i'm pulled over i'm not talking my
way out of that [ __ ] i'm getting two
tickets
exactly one for one for the traffic
violation and the other just for uh
talking too much
i think maybe one of the most impressive
things loki can do is he's able to sneak
people in and out of asgard right under
the watchful eye of eindhoven
like i mean that guy is supposed to be
all-seeing that is crazy impressive to
me because like
one of my favorite heimdall moments is
when is in thor the dark world when
malekith's invisible ship start
approaching asgard and no one can see
them but heimdall's like
wait a minute right and then he jumps
onto an invisible ship
that nobody can see yes so like if you
can fool heimdall
that guy like you're next level so yes i
do like that
loki is a great number three but number
two we're gonna have to go
with the man the myth the conductor of
the train
zola himself i know it's unsurprising
that i would
give zola the number two spot but like
zola is
one smart uh computery man because red
skull may have had all the ambition to
make hydra the ruling force on the
planet during his time on the planet
via the power of the tester act but zola
was the one with the brains
and the technical expertise to pull it
off i mean
he was smart enough to know not to take
the suicide pill which is great
um and he was able to orchestrate
hydra's actions while working
directly under the nose of shield of
course this happens between the events
of
captain america one and winter soldier
when the united states take him in to
work on
various uh nerd stuff they needed some
nerds instead of like hey
you worked for a hydra come on and we
could trust you you couldn't trust him
no and he basically figured out a way to
be immortal through his ability to
digitize
his consciousness so even though zola is
technically
dead the consciousness of zola is still
around to terrorize everyone which is uh
great because
we need some more zola i love that he's
around
all right number one probably inevitable
just as he says is of course thanos the
mad titan
yes probably the smartest villain in the
mcu i would say it's tough
to tough to argue with his his track
record and success
he's the king of delegation he doesn't
need to micromanage sends his employees
out to collect the stones for him
granted this doesn't always work out as
planned but fairly successful i mean
he accomplishes his plan and retrieves
all six infinity stones
and what does he do he wipes out half
the universe
dude thanos he had he had a vision and
he carried it out
he's exactly he's undistracted by
petty squabbles he's undistracted by
familial emotions and drama like oh
daughter you toss that chick right off
the cliff as soon as he
is he already had to he's like family
vacation with my daughter but i need to
get the soul stone
bye-bye that [ __ ] well here's the
craziest thing why thanos is probably
the smartest one in the mcu
he almost does it a second time he
almost accomplishes
all of these things twice like it's like
talk about perseverance
talk about sisyphus the boulder rolls
back down the hill
and what does he do he rolls it right
back up so
i think with all that that has to make
thanos the smartest right i mean he's
got to be the smartest villain
oh yeah yeah he's he's like he's no
slouch i mean like he's basically
titans tony stark yes i mean like we we
hear in infinity war when he's talking
to doctor strange
about how like he wished that the
scientists of titan listen to him and
like with his
his plans on you know i guess basically
genocide on titan
right and you know even though it was
the ramblings of a madman
it was rooted in rationality and science
to thanos to the
to the rationale of a person who thinks
murder is a proper
solution to rational or the rationality
to the irrational oh yes
and like i i was thinking about this the
other day
who knows what type of experiments
thanos was even up to you
during his time while he was alive i
mean like
who knew look and who even knows what
was on that ship that crashed
onto the planet during the events of it
right in the final battle an avengers
endgame what if there was what if he was
experimenting
with some venom symbiotes
oh he's a scientist through his hand i
forget that thanos is a scientist
and you don't know what's on that ship
so we could be getting some venom what
on that ship oh that would be amazing
but yes that was great and we are going
to dive into our bite size questions
next
but first of course we got to do a word
from those
amazing people that help bring big
question to you guys
because i mean that's just what we do
and one of the people that do that is of
course
cut clothing now whether your co-workers
are just seeing you over a zoom screen
or in person
you need to look professional and
dressing competently tells people
that you are competent yourself though
you don't have to sacrifice comfort
for timeless style and for that there's
cuts clothing the folks that cut its
clothing have taken a classic
men's fashion staple the plain tee and
refined it
combining premium quality with the
minimalist aesthetic
cuts founder steve barelli reinvented
the t-shirt and made what gq magazine
calls the only shirt worth wearing their
signature pika pro
tri-blend tee is a bold new take on a
classic design
i have some cut shirts myself and not
only do they make me look great but they
make me
feel really nice on the inside too it's
just really it's just a nice fit it
feels good on the skin
now i don't really have to go to
important business meetings all that
often but
if i did i would not feel out of place
in a cuts
shirt because they're just that good
it's not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing
it's office leisure apparel for the
sport of business
get 15 off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
bigquestionthatiscutsclothing.com
bigquestion for 15 off the only shirt
worth wearing even if it's easier now to
leave the house and go
places it doesn't mean running some
errands is necessarily
fun like me to go to the pharmacy to
pick up prescriptions i don't need them
to know my
face when i pick up my shameful
prescriptions i need that to be discreet
god knows what's growing on me or in me
at any given time and it takes
medication to keep that under control
this is not done
naturally this is made by science amazon
pharmacy is the super easy way to save
time and money and not have to wait in
line at the actual physical pharmacy
behind
the old women that take 94 minutes to
make a five dollar transaction
i don't know where i put that five
dollar bill in my purse it's because
your purse was made in 1930
and is the size of a cargo chest that
you would take on a ship
to travel from london all the way to the
new world to seek your fortune
amazon pharmacy coordinates with your
doctor to receive your prescriptions and
then they deliver those medications
straight to your door
they work with most insurance plans i'm
already buying stuff on amazon because
of the convenience and easy delivery
it just makes sense to do the same with
my prescriptions something i don't want
to worry about running out of i want to
spend my newfound freedom
to leave my house safely doing fun stuff
not waiting at the pharmacy take a chore
off your to-do list with amazon pharmacy
amazon prime members can save on
prescription medication when not using
insurance and get
free two-day delivery learn more at
amazon.com
bigquestion that's amazon.com
bigquestion
amazon.com big
question it's time for the most
electable segment of this show uh just a
little
nibble of knowledge it's time for some
bite-sized questions
so what's your first bite-sized question
tommy i'm so glad you asked mt kilgore
salmon
via twitter heard of it uh a little
social media platform where people can
politely discuss their differences
without interference from villains or
any other nefarious forces
who would live longer thor or superman
that's a really good question that's a
really good question kilgore salmon
that's a really great uh twitter handle
by the way
i do love it now both heroes have a
propensity for long lifespans i mean
thor is of course the god of thunder
born on asgard which is also the source
of his powers and
superman is an alien hailing from
krypton powered by
our yellow sun and both have the ability
to live very long and hopefully
productive lives but which one could
live the longest now let's think about
this
let's start with thor now both the mcu
and marvel
comics have established that the yes
guardians live a very long time but they
do
eventually die as do we all i mean death
it just waits for no one i mean
everyone's every we're all gonna die
except for zola really
now thor's grandfather boar is long gone
by the time we meet
our golden haired wonder boy in the red
cape and we eventually see odin go all
sparkly mist in four ragnarok
the final odin sleep if you will and the
same thing also happens to
frigga in for the dark world when during
her funeral she turns into little
sparkly dust and thor is even aware of
his own mortality
in infinity war etre warns thor at the
star forge that he's about to take the
full force of the star
and that it will kill him to which thor
replies only if i
die but he doesn't die in the moment but
it does at least confirm that thor
knows death is a possibility for him um
and
of course you know watching everyone die
at the beginning of that movie
is definitely a a big hint that death is
a possibility for asgardians in the
comics thor
has died and been reborn so he's a
little bit more mortality elastic there
though thor's death does create the
paradox that we love so much because
if thor dies and is then reborn is that
the same thor
or a newer thor or the thor of theseus
you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
as for superman the super man
he has certainly died on screen in the
snyder verse as we remember
in the events of batman v superman the
man
uh he got killed by mr doomsday and he
died for our wallets in the special
edition comic book in the 90s but both
times he came back because you just
can't keep a good kryptonian
down okay the long history of superman
in the comics has established him to be
pretty much immortal which is you know
pretty pretty convenient if you don't
like dying
um can't relate now as we look at both
thor and superman's histories in the
comics they've both lived long
impressive lives
and we've seen a prime superman from
like 85 000 years
in the future looking all golden and
beautiful there's even a comic where
superman
makes it to the end of the universe some
like five billion years from now and he
still looks
like he got off the bus from smallville
like he's just he just doesn't age that
well i mean just
i think it's the lotion he uses i think
maybe he's
it's i think it's aloe vera aloe vera is
a secret now thor has made it to the end
of the universe as well
however much like his father odin he
starts to show his age now old king thor
is said to be one of the oldest gods to
ever live
but without some magic golden apples to
restore his youth and vigor
he will pass on to valhalla just like
his father just from old age because
that's just you know old age comes from
us all it's very sad
now while both superman and thor have
the potential to live
very very long lives thor does appear to
actually age up while superman just
stays looking young and vivacious so
superman would probably live longer than
thor in that situation so
there's the answer but good question i
love that question great question
all right our next question a little
less of a downer i think not that that
question was a downer but maybe
one that's not going to make us go to
dark places in our minds
bossy the grape says uh when venom eats
something or someone does the food go
into eddie brock's stomach
that is a really good question i do like
that boss the grape eddie brock and
venom have a
symbiotic relationship though i'm not
sure what great benefits eddie is
pulling from this partnership excuse me
but whatever i'm in the 2018 sony film
venom appears to eat a robber at the
convenience store and you don't actually
get to see it
which sucks but you know that's just how
pg-13 works so
whatever but when eddie later wakes up
we see him smacking his lips as if he
just enjoyed a delicious meal that
is [ __ ] disgusting is that robber in
eddie's stomach
well let's look at the evidence now in
the comics venom has had a few hosts
over the years
most of them at some point were forced
to eat body parts
animals a scroll a deadpool and it
appears that the host can certainly at
the very least
taste what the venom symbiote consumes
when mech gargan scorpion was venom they
consumed a squirrel
and mac actually admitted to liking the
taste of the squirrel which is really
gross
i've never had squirrel i have yeah i
don't recommend it
and as a side note mac probably ate the
most organisms
of any venom he was really into eating
uh just
people and just things is really gross
but hey it's matt gargan
he he wore a scorpion suit for a good
chunk of his life so
doesn't necessarily make the best
decisions anyway are these tasty treats
being passed down into the host's
digestive system
nice venom number seven from 2018 has
that answer because as explained to
eddie brock by the maker
the green saliva that comes from the
venom's mouth is actually the extrusion
of waste product absorbed by the
symbiote and while the host
may taste anything that the venom
symbiote eats the fact
is that the human nachos with squirrels
on the side that has been consumed by
the symbiote does not go
into the human's tummies instead it gets
absorbed by the symbiote
and any of the waste is extruded out of
venom's mouth via that green saliva
which is uh
pretty gross but hey bon appetit
disgusting
delicious humans great energy for uh
doing some more killing here i go
killing again oh boy with that human
energy
so there you go great question bossy the
great and now it is time for the best
and most fun part of the show it's the
box of scraps
of scraps now today's box of scraps
question is
what vehicle from any comic book movie
slash
nerd sphere anything do you wish that
you
owned that is a very
good question i mean i have like the
obvious
everyone knows what a uh han solo fan i
am so the falcon would be dope
uh millennium falcon all right the
delorean from back to the future is
great but that car sucks in real life
so oh yeah it's you know it seems like a
very cramped vehicle anyway
i'm gonna i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for
something slightly abstract here
i'm gonna choose the car that as a kid i
wanted
the most and that was the mach 5 from
speed racer
uh okay that's a sick car i
love speed racer i love the concept of
the cartoon was
so straightforward it's like this kid is
just gonna race at the end of every
cartoon
and there's gonna be hijinks from the
other racers and the mach 5 is such a
great car
that it's going to be able to overcome i
actually think the speed racer movie
from the bro from the machine is one of
the most so
good so underrated and i think so
underrated by dude
i just don't know i wonder if that movie
came out now
if it would do better or maybe there's
just the cynicism of the prop maybe the
i think the property just wasn't
respected enough by like moviegoers to
like see a live-action version of it but
i really
i loved that movie uh bro the
cinematography of that movie
is just next level uh it is so
underrated so yes so go see go watch
speed racer if you can
and uh yeah mine's the mach 5 what about
you i do like that
um mine is definitely not a uh a vehicle
really
in the traditional sense like it it has
no wheels but
i do like me a good tardis from doc
whenever i'm stressed out it looks like
this day sucks i'm just like
i wish a tardis would just materialize
into my room yeah so i could just
just disappear from the [ __ ]
honestly like the tardis is
the ultimate vehicle in my eyes it's
literally
a mansion a time traveling mansion that
you can just go anywhere in time and
space it's literally the best and i'm
just a huge doctor who
yeah um nerd so i i had to say the
tardis man that's me
that's all yeah that's a great answer
but yo
the mach 5 um from speed racer man
that's a dope vehicle yeah yeah yeah
both legit both legit too legit to quit
yeah big head gang got the vehicles we
got the big heads
peaches and cream right in style
landing in his tardis me room in the mud
which if i was driving the mach 5 would
probably look like a bear on a tricycle
i'm probably way too big to sit in it
i'd be like bro
my knees are my dude
ain't no girl when i wanted to go into a
phone booth with a stranger
it's like hey wait coming to my police
box like ah we're good
stranger uh we're gonna go with the guy
with a cool car like all right
that's understandable that car looks so
small with that guy
it's too small for his body uh all right
hey man
i know that feel i literally drive the
tiniest toyota prius
so like that is literally me uh all of
my friends are like empty what are you
doing get a bigger car i'm just like no
i'm saving money on gas
you get a bigger car yeah but that is it
for this episode of big question i want
to thank tommy beck told as always
for making peaches and cream happen the
in the best way possible
mine thank you pleasure my treasure this
was yes always a blast to do this show
with you
um thank you follow tommy of course at
tommy bechtold wherever you can find him
follow me at mastertainment but most
importantly follow new rock stars
wherever we are especially on youtube
where you can hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications whenever we
upload dope [ __ ] which is 247
365. send your big questions using the
hashtag bigquestion
and subscribe to our podcast feed
wherever we have podcasts and give us a
nice rating
and review because that [ __ ] helps a lot
seriously
any rating or review that you can give
please do because we would appreciate
that
so so much and we will see you guys next
time bye
take it easy
[Music]
you